fifty-two seconds of logos since time
began narration it may be fought on a
grand scale or within the heart of a
single individual or even a child so
what is it do in the shadows grand scale
single individual we aren't even a full
minute into this movie and he's already
stepping on what he just said seconds
ago they call themselves simply the hand
sounds kinda Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtle
II to me or what I used to call my
girlfriend legend tells of a unique
Wario kung-fu Panda stole this narration
when it came out three years later a
motherless daughter
that's literally impossible but okay a
name miss Electra roll credits can I go
home now I can't she wanted me to feel
this what it's like to have nowhere to
go nowhere to turn the security guy who
only has one job looks away from his
computer to listen to this fearful
soliloquy and mrs. Electra busting in
anyone who wants to complain about
shaky-cam fight footage need only look
at this film to see how terrible things
can truly be why not because it's a
windy must be an extremely drafty
hallway and we just didn't notice before
because the guy she just knocked out
didn't have any hair guess it's all true
the red outfit the knives if the skies
had several run-ins with her prior to
this moment as he explained minutes
earlier
what is he realizing right now that he
didn't already know at what point in
martial arts training do you learn the
time altering swishing seem to be a
common thread through all supernatural
kung-fu movies
why'd she have to a parade to the back
of the room to throw her sigh at him she
was just right looking behind him she's
being awfully showy but that may be her
style given that outfit this thing is
like two feet long from the back of the
chair through the guy's chest but here
it's like 10 inches and not a drop of
blood on it
she probably coated that thing in rain-x
err in this case blood X she kills this
guy with no explanation for who he is
what he has done where we are or why we
should care the only reason I know his
name is DeMarco is because I've googled
it with all the power band that the
treasure continues to elude us and
because of all the vagaries of that
sentence his character objectives elude
us these super evil martial arts masters
need a conference room for presentations
and client meetings
wait can she sensed that this asshole
has arrived in his parking he checks for
bullets out on the street where he can
be seen by human people
why he'll always do this to my DNA
shaving your incredibly long hair would
be a good way to make sure your DNA
isn't secretly lying around also asking
a question of a longtime acquaintance
for exposition cliche money for this
contract killing is delivered on site of
the killing and seconds after said
killing took place does that make any
sense at all to anyone even get laid
dude have you seen her not the best most
puffs oh man a drag poor Terence Stamp
into this didn't they is this a test
something he's just not that into you
there's no crying in samurai rite-aid
for all your assassin needs and her
groceries are we really just watching
her set up her house if the camera
wasn't moving so much I would assume
this was another Paranormal Activity
movie OCD this much underwater footage
generally suggests Sajjad or James Bond
or at least a lake placid type storyline
but this is a martial-arts thriller so
get the out of the water electric well
considering she dove into a lake this is
admittedly creepy but also obviously a
dream she should recognize his fake also
her flashbacks are really skirting the
line between memories and hallucinations
what the she don't in at dusk or dawn
but comes up at high noon the hell also
Jennifer Turner isn't swimming in my
lake in this scene wait I mean she isn't
coming up for my air in the sweep
Jennifer isn't floating in my you know
what she's gone that's all I'm trying to
say here Jennifer Garner is damn huh the
end
Nexen what the hell's this girl doing
running around in here she broke in to
jog that's what the boxes is she moving
in I thought she only needed to be there
a couple days early I understand that
she's supposed to be a supernatural
ninja warrior assassin and all but she
would have to see into the future to
know she was going to flail her arm up
at just the right time for her to stick
her in the wall with a box cutter she
can well the story is based in mostly
Asian decor and martial arts yet we have
Greek letters making an appearance every
once in a while also the Greek letters
on our necklace are just as Greek as the
martial arts in this movie our agent
this looks like it actually spells
electro and the title side but the movie
spelled its literal Greek letters are
hard this is the second supernatural
thing Elektra has done and this girl
seems to be pretty chill about it I
can't tell what is a dream or was a
flashback anymore doesn't seem like much
time has passed between her waking up
and wanting to take insomnia medication
we're seeing flash-forwards now
screenwriters seem to have some sort of
goal to write as little dialogue as
possible this montage serves only one
purpose to remind you that Elektra is in
way better shape than you are if she
could actually do this she would be
jacked ish watch
Oliver flashbacks are now happening at
once music is sitting here we have that
in common
not gonna name sin I'm walking maybe
she's dry reading a book or watching a
movie freely excite Kevin I've ever been
to as a copy of 13 going on 30
hi you look cool why because she almost
stuck you in the arm with a box cutter
and busted you for stealing I'm no 13
year old girl that I wouldn't imagine
those things are cool
did you know today's Christmas it's 20
minutes into the movie before they
decide to mention it's set at Christmas
electron like the tragedy you mean this
movie has he already seen the movie is
this the darkest dinner ever held since
the 13th warrior guys I think it is I
read a college level and I'm doing
Algebra one on my own well she's clearly
five years better at reading than she is
at map if she just switched over there
why did not see her as he walked back
into the house she must still be mid
swoosh and he still can't see her we're
now thirty minutes into the superhero
movie and except for the very quick
opening sequence there have been no
action scenes in this film but this is
like the fourth traumatic flashback
these flashbacks seem to add more
confusion based on the original owner of
her necklace her mom is Elektra
or maybe electril and then she just took
it off her dead mother and decided it
was her name what good morning you just
got a delivery so she's asleep and she
gets a phone call telling her about a
delivery and then she walks to the table
to open said delivery my question is
it's a fireplace been going all night
long
starter of course the target is the
neighbor and his kid they're like the
only other people on this island
she's clearly hired for her murdering
talents and not her brains exotic
supernatural martial arts master who can
sense bad guys parking outside her
apartment needs a very unsportsmanlike
scope on her boat assassin grows a
conscience cliche it should probably be
some assassin's code that would cover
not getting attached to anyone and if
there is a slightly awkward dinner
shouldn't keep her from killing these
people also if I paid some amazing
martial arts assassin to kill someone
and they just shot them with a crossbow
from a distance I would feel like I
didn't get my money's worth
the Asian blues brothers just appeared
for no reason
can we talk inside if they sent Elektra
to kill these two what the hell are
these ninjas doing here is this a case
of the left the hand not knowing what
the right the hand is doing these ninjas
are supposed to be trained assassins
also yeah this guy is just chilling up
here waiting to get impossibly stabbed
through the roof also does she ever stab
people directly are always through stuff
you know a guy is really working for the
hand if when you stab them they don't
bleed they like zombies in that way
thankfully for the second bad guy the
first bad guy bursts into a green cloud
of gas upon being killed because I have
no clue actually can you go to your
bedroom for a minute Abby I want you to
be alone so the Green Smoke ninjas have
an opportunity to kill you that's some
astoundingly bad aim right there she can
see the future now is she the Omega 13
in superhero form so she was able to
predict what would happen if she walked
out of this room but not this even
though she knew the guy was about to
walk into the house that dart gun fires
a lot of darts without needing to be
reloaded also I suppose there's an
old-fashioned elegance to everyone using
knives and arrows for murder
this dude's on how kills himself and
more mysterious green dust happens
what's coming next will be worse I hope
this isn't a sequel teaser no overhead
lights in this boardroom at all did have
to reschedule meetings after a rainy day
your forces are not domination since the
dude who just sent two assassins to take
out a 13 year old girl my forces will
not be defeated by a mere woman that's
racist typhoid decides to use her power
on this guy who is on her own fucking
team for the sole purpose of showing the
viewer what her power is why is she now
by herself and not making sure her most
bestest friends that she is known for a
half a day or protected what's with the
shadow over his eyes is there supposed
to be some big reveal for whom the zoo's
like we can't already tell blind my ass
leave your money on the table line pool
hustler seems like it should be pretty
far down on the list of jobs for a blind
former martial arts master I wonder how
many cars he picked up his blind valet
he did that same walk same perfume is he
from writing she told you what she
actually does for a living mr. Malone
probably not because no one tells anyone
anything in this movie electric it's
owned by a blind pool player and yeah
it's stared stamped so it's kind of okay
but also this movie has made her out to
be the kind of badass who wouldn't get
owned like this in a bar so graffiti of
a giant bird plays the ex machina Eagles
roll from Lord of the Rings even the
Scooby Doo eyes inside a portrait know
not to move when someone is looking but
at the end the degree this evil leaves
the scene where the hunted people are to
fly back to his evil henchman boss to
become one of his tattoos
instead of just you know calling the
dude and telling him where the targets
are you really kill people for a living
yeah why it's what I'm good at you're
also good at predicting the future how
about giving sports betting a shot
well well Reluctant assassin wait a
reluctant assassin protecting a kid with
supernatural abilities out in the
country against shadowy gangsters
insisting on said kids death adding some
time travel in weird cgi faces and you
got yourself a looper baby wait that
bird that came out of the graffiti is
real and he can actually see it do a
movie she's my friend this poor kids bar
for friendship is don't try to murder me
disrespecting a good meditation session
this girl does not seem worth saving you
were going to kill me but you didn't so
now you should kiss me face and the
daughter who objects to everything
somehow slept through this this big-ass
farmhouse definitely has more than one
bedroom also yeah right as though a
trained assassin like electro would
allow an open cracked window overnight
use the cellar there's a tunnel take you
out pass your due to the trees why is
there a giant tunnel under the house is
it a prohibition thing why would you do
this what makes this movie weird and bad
is that like this or Electress
precognitive abilities just seem kind of
like magic in another wise normal world
the x-men are mutants Thor in Superman
or aliens
Batman is rich this this just seems like
a bouncer with a magic bullet repelling
skin so does he have the same
premonition powers that Elektra has or
did he read McCabe's thoughts as he was
killing him and the director decided to
represent that with a shot of them
running through the woods I'll bet you a
thousand bucks shirt before Elektra is
you'll be right of course but completely
unable to collect on that bet seeing as
how you're super dead now but her plant
killing power is impressive but she's
moving at a pace that would let a damn
turtle get away from her no problem
cheating ptolemy capron he can make it
outrun the flying tattoo wolf hats this
girl is 13 not 3 there's no reason she
shouldn't be able to keep her mouth shut
while hiding
they would have a much harder time
avoiding this creature if it didn't
announce itself with a bright light
blasting through the forest that's the
problem with wolves no canine can resist
the get the stick trick
another perfect instance for a gun some
salesman is going to make a killing
introducing guns to this gang sudden
lesbian kiss for drama this chick is
like a Dementor if Dementors were styled
like they were a punk-rocker in a Law &
Order episode or a young Elektra
tenacious T will defeat this demon with
the greatest song in the world what this
girl went from school child and
distressed have possibly gifted some how
to train for deadly combat in like five
minutes what if I had failed good
question
I always knew your heart was pure you
simply needed to see it for yourself
after murdering like a load of people
and growing to hate yourself why even be
a spider if you're just going to melt
into the fucking floor did anyone ever
fish out the suicide from the bathroom
on the left she's still there with his
guts all over the floor I mean I do not
ages ago but what the fuck is going on
I'm starting to think the wind is a
sentient being that warns her when
trouble is near and congratulate her
when she succeeded clever girl
yes I also saw Jurassic Park Total
Recall and all the other movies that
have used clever girl
goddamnit hero is somehow made more
badass with a demonstration of her
twirling things any explanation so far
for why there are dozens of sheets
flying around constantly during this
battle I'm guessing it's basic kung-fu
magic bullet but wondered if the movie
might possibly have an alternative
explanation this asshole doesn't kill
her right now
I mean I've held my tongue long enough
plus 10 cents for every time physics has
been super weird in this movie just how
many tattoos of snakes is this dickhead
supposed to have anyway whoa
tattoo bass neck missiles also if this
dude we could sum tattoos of puppies and
kittens he could do big business at
birthday parties number-one rule when
running from flying snakes don't run
into a key mace well I'd comment on this
big finale fight scene if it wasn't so
cut to hell that I literally have no
idea what's happening that's what you
get for just standing there with second
time in this movie this asshole doesn't
kill electro when he has the chance keep
going Elektra so the thing her dad did
that was presented as basically abuse
earlier is now what's keeping her alive
Electro's memories are useless
yep no bud you've just killed a ghost
some definite bullshit this apology
isn't directed at me for having to watch
this god-awful movie
cool they say can puncture the skin of a
rhino for my ow oh yes that's awesome
what just go
I got nowhere else to go
I like your dress because they've got
these incredible boobs to fill it out
they are shined a shiny demon
in the middle of the road
you
tomate suwari no koi yo so say hey ho
new Oh chica say y para que ma show yo
Coco - what imagine over there is she
not a song do you wanna build a snowman
you tell you I'm coming Taemin become a